you know everyone of course obsessed as
we have to be with kovid
yeah and what we're all dealing with
with covet and everyone's constantly
trying to figure out oh my god my throat
hurts
could i possibly um
you actually uh one of the main symptoms
for kova that everyone knows
is not having a sense of smell yeah yeah
yeah you have never had a sense of smell
is that right
that is true yeah you were born without
a sense of smell
as far as i know because i don't
remember ever being able to smell so i
think it was congenital although
something may have happened so i i mean
i didn't i wasn't like a very um
i didn't fall and hit my head a lot like
i wasn't like a um
uh fearless kid you know like kids that
you know climb up things i mean i did
break an arm but i don't remember having
a head injury
so as far as i know it's yeah i've never
had it and
you know yeah and now here it is being a
thing so when i
even mentioned to people that don't know
me or or something um
you know i'm like oh i can't smell like
it'll just come out they're like oh
are you worried it's like oh no i've
never been able to smell right and
people are kind of like oh
oh oh never mind but it is a question
like wait how then you get the questions
you know
what can you taste and it's like you
know
no but but i don't have nuance there's
so many little subtleties that i've
learned as i've gotten older
and i didn't even realize it all growing
up because as a kid the only thing you
really pay attention to
what smells is like you know something
like pizza or cookies or farts
you know but then at some point when i
was doing second city
and i was in the touring company so
we're we're in like a nine passenger bus
or a van and we're traveling around you
know going from chicago to like ohio
state or something and you pass through
a um
there were two things i remember going
past like some field or farm
and everybody was like ah roll up the
windows because it smelled like cow [ __ ]
or something
and then once those windows were up
there was i remember there being another
moment where people like oh
today because do you have your shoes off
i was like yeah i was like laying down
in the back seat they're like will you
put them on please i didn't realize i
had the stinkiest feet
on earth and that that you kind of had
no idea had no idea and it stayed with
me
my first couple years at snl at some
point it kind of like
went away i don't know how or what i
didn't necessarily
address it in a you know meaningful way
but it kind of disappeared but early on
um the felt you know tom and eric over
at snl they would put my sneakers in a
tupperware
because in a tupperware like my yeah
and again i had no idea and it's super
it was super duper embarrassing
but um but they found a way to make it
less embarrassing for me and more
importantly to make it less
more tolerable for them yeah and then
yeah i i've got nothing i i know
it's uh it's toxic waste you know yeah
oh 100
but but but like my little girl uh daisy
she just
last week realized that otis found this
out ages ago but she
um we have a couple olive trees like in
our front yard
and she grabbed a bunch of the leaves
and she was like smelling like that and
she was
daddy smell and i'm like i can't smell
it she was no no smell
and i go up and i go like that i go yeah
nothing and she's like no no you gotta
go like this
i'm like no no honey i am and it was it
was like you know like a comedy routine
and
she's just like looking at me and
doesn't get it but to see your little
kid be able to do something that you
can't do
and and have a sense of like a memory of
it
is is bizarre you know i mean i can't
touch my toes
either but smell you'd think i'd still
be able to do you don't come back
i swear to god when you least expect it
yeah but i mean if you had to lose one
one cents out of your five which one
would you lose
which would you choose i think my sense
of justice
oh okay well you know we're getting
there then i could act with impunity all
the time
right you can take you you can get to
the highest heights that way yeah
apparently it doesn't it doesn't hold
you back
you